hey what's up guys welcome back to our
channel my name is samuel and i'm amanda
and this is the samuel and amanda show
where we talk about
money marriage and life and let's face
it you gotta like money and we talk
about money marriage
[Music]
marriage is bliss and also life you know
generally things what's going on what's
happening so if you enjoy our channel
please do me a massive favor and amanda
my favorite hands yeah hit the like
button also subscribe to see more
absolutely so what have you been up to
recently oh my goodness this week i mean
do you want the rosy version or do you
want like the real oh i want the rosy
version only
likes my story's short because he hates
me like going on so what what what's
been what's been the issue my love
basically just having issues with
tenants
yeah
and this is the thing this is why my
goal used to be to own a thousand houses
but then as we got more and more and
more properties over the years we kind
of came to the conclusion that we'd step
into doing bigger deals commercial deals
development deals um little houses are
great but if the thing is if you've got
four or five little houses and you're
making a full-time income off that
brilliant but to scale it and try and
make millions of small houses can have
problems so tenant problems let me guess
in fact i already know so there's a
funding but um but hmos right yeah hmo
so it's yeah it's one that i'm just now
trying to
change the use of yeah so we don't have
it as hmo anymore and but listen
this sounds so negative now i need the
rosy version like
let's let's just be real though just put
things into perspective yeah
we have made a full-time living and
lived a life of luxury off the back of
hmo oh yeah they're great they're great
but occasionally you just get one or two
every so often so what talk to me about
the downside of hmos and then i want to
talk about um how to fill rooms fast how
to fill um hlos and properties quickly
how to be a good landlord we're going to
give you guys some tips i hope that
sounds good um but just talk to me about
like some of the problems that we have
with the odd one of our hms when that
happens i think when you get one bad
apple
if that's when the issues start because
usually if you get a group of people
that just get on then the house just
ticks and it's fine but when you get one
person that's problematic and it's
stirring things between people and then
annoying the other ones then it's like a
headache for you because it's just like
oh great now
i think as well in terms of tenants it's
really annoying when you've got not just
one bad tenant that you can just kick
out but if you've got one bad tenant
that tries to turn the others yeah um
you know or i mean we had a situation
with with with this particular human
mind where we
to be fair we've had the property now
for about seven years and it's always
been great the prop the first tenant
that we moved in seven years ago we put
a quite a low rent because there was a
refurb going on at the time and you know
he moved in and we just put a low rent
um
and then the second tenant we put a
little bit of a low rent because this
was like seven years ago and then
everyone else that came in they've all
gone but these two tenants have still
been in the property paying a low rent
right like a really low rent yeah
and we've
we've not put it up because we kind of
just knew that it would tick them off
yeah and we also know that they can't
really afford it and it's just so
they're paying a little bit they told
all the other they've been telling all
the other tenants oh man we only paid
this much and
we then thought should we kick them out
should we up the rent yeah and it ended
up everyone's moved out apart from in
the video
those two that we went out
so it's like the bad people have stayed
the annoying ones those are always
arguing and causing issues so now so not
not right now but we had a situation
last week where we had two bad tenants
not that bad and three empty rooms yeah
so we just um
bribed them out yeah okay
so now we have no tenants and no income
oh my gosh i know so now we're good but
it's okay because now we're gonna fill
the property from scratch with great
tenants start again start fresh put some
new carpets in put some paint probably
change the kitchen over yeah but this is
it's a bit of a headache it's we're not
making any money on that particular
property right now but i think you need
to look across you need to look across
the board you can't just focus on well
although your job is to focus on that
one pass property right now but you
can't just focus on the bad you have to
look at the overall oh yeah overall
everything's great it's a bit like
imagine if you um you know
with anything if you go to a school and
it's like hey how are you getting on
school kids well this is one person
that's really annoying it's like yeah
what about all the good people
you know so yes this is one tenant yes
this is one house but it all be sorted
so what i want to talk about in this
podcast or video is tips to to renting
rooms out quickly because i actually
think finding a good property is not
enough okay do you agree that yeah i
agree i agree it's what you do with the
problem it is it's what you do with it
and it's also how you make it because if
you've got you could get a really good
deal you could buy a house from a deal
saucer
and you could buy the house but if you
don't know
the tips and tricks in how to manage the
property and how to get tenants in that
property quickly guess what's gonna
happen you're gonna get beat by some
punk ass whose house is cheaper whose
house is worse but they know what to do
so first tip i have okay is to
okay when you put your adverts up maybe
on spare room dot co uk whatever is to
refresh the ads every single day yeah i
mean how important is that really really
important because then when you refresh
it then it goes to the top of the page
and also i think you can pay extra to
have it as a featured thing and when
it's featured it doesn't even cost that
much more
20 pounds or something really but yeah
refresh but but it costs nothing to
refresh it nothing yeah when you refresh
the ad then it means that your property
comes right to the top and people don't
know about this kind of stuff no and
then their property sits on page four
mainly on page one everyone else is
adding so then it's just being and a lot
of a lot of letting agents they're not
really bothered if they've got 20
properties they're not going to put
yours at number one
so make sure that you're logging in you
have the long details you're refreshing
the ad every single day second thing is
it's really important how the shots are
taken oh yeah
really really important like you don't
want the room to be looking dark and
dingy you want the light to be on get
like a nice wide shot like on our
iphones now you can get a wide shot of
the room and yeah get the best angle
yeah make sure that the property is like
you've got you've got even if you're not
going to rent the rooms out with bedding
and furnishings even if you're going to
rent it out just like a mattress and
that's it in your hmos put all the
furniture in make it look beautiful but
then when you advertise it advertise it
beautiful show and beautiful but then
just tell the perspective tenant oh
actually is going to be coming on
furnish because a lot of because most
housemates like to bring their own
duvets and stuff like that yeah i just
wanted you to see what it looks like
done up and then that's why
the difference between one that's done
up with a bright orange pillow and
pictures and it's just gonna sell better
yeah
you've done this you actually used to as
a business
to furnish other people's properties
talk to me about that yeah i think it's
really really important because you want
good solid furniture as well that's
going to last but obviously you don't
have to spend like loads and loads of
money but you know you can even with a
small budget you can make a room look
wow and also the colors so if you use
like bright colored cushions to to um to
set the bed they stand out then on the
photo then we're just looking down like
a stream of different adverts when you
have a bright color then it pops and
then it draws people's attention so i
think it's really important to use
bright colors you know make it look
aesthetically pleasing where someone
would actually could imagine themselves
you know living yeah and another thing
is i think the reason that that tenant
that we moved in seven years ago paid
such a low rent okay hear me because
this is really important
really important is because we've got
five rooms
and when that first tenant came to look
around
and we showed them all the rooms oh we
got this room this room this room this
room in this room
they knew
that we had five empty rooms
right they've got loads of choice he put
them in the driver's seat and then when
he goes they negotiated with us a really
cheap man
however
if i was going back now
rewind seven years i would lock the
doors on four of the rooms and only show
them one room
so important because
when you show them just one room
they're going to
um it's almost like
if you confuse them you lose them if you
show if you give people too much choice
it makes them think oh well what's wrong
with this house what's wrong with these
what they're all empty so just show them
one and it makes the whole one
what do you think could you just again
you've managed hundreds
don't you think well i mean it depends
maybe show them two rooms yeah exactly
because if they want a double room or a
single room you can show them like okay
this is the double that you can have
this is a single that you can have but
can't you just
when they inquire ask them what they're
looking for and go
perfect we've got that and only show
them what they want yes yes yes i guess
so i guess sir i mean i think you're
probably right i think you're probably
right definitely definitely right
in that room yeah i confuse them you
lose them fairly enough yeah you became
really good at closing tenants talk to
me about that as well about how yeah
so because it's a waste of time when
you're like showing lots of people
around you don't want to be like
constantly go into that house back and
forth so in the end it was just like
right
first of all ask them all the questions
what are you looking for make sure that
this this house this room takes what
you're pre-qualified yeah pre-qualifying
them making sure that they can pay
they've got a good job whatever and then
when you meet them it's basically like
you kind of go into it just like as if
like it's a done deal you've now just
come to just see the rooms to confirm
so it's very presumptive and it's just
like oh hey nice to meet you and then
even when i'd be talking to them i'd be
like oh and then you could put this
there oh you mentioned you had a table
and chair oh you could pop back there
and then you sort of like and then they
almost feel like oh but then they can
also see themselves i guess in the room
and then at the end of it it's not just
like okay well anyway ring me to let me
know it's almost like okay so when are
you looking to move in oh you know yeah
and then like she's a babe and then tell
them this is the process
and then you basically just talk to them
as if it's a done deal you know what
makes you know what makes me laugh
sometimes people say like oh samuel he's
uh samuel he's he's he's a salesman
right i was a salesman it's like yeah
and that's what property is yeah like
you don't get paid from property you get
paid from people
if you can't sell to people if you can't
close i am a salesman that's why i'm so
good at property the two are not
mutually exclusive property is
a numbers game it's formulas it's
numbers crunching the numbers due
diligence but at the same time it's a
people game
because how much is a property even
worth it's only worth what someone's
prepared to pay for it so your job is to
sell the property find out what people
want give it to them close love what you
were saying when you asked you're asking
open questions as well like like
when would you be looking to move in
yeah questions that start with when what
how where not would not do not r
because if you ask questions that start
with would and do an r then the answer
can be no yeah she has some open
questions so basically what so you're
showing tenants around and you're kind
of just wait every time you do a viewing
you're assuming that of course they're
going to take this yeah because we've
talked about it on the phone why would
you then come and view it
even naturally of course
yeah because
so another thing is when you when they
ring you then you need to tell them that
all the particulars up front yeah
exactly videos yeah everything deposit
the rent everything and then you're
gonna go right does that sound good
right so so the viewing
is more
to just check that everything you said
is correct yeah exactly and if it is of
course they'll rent it from you of
course i love that yeah that's why i
married her
i'm sure she closed me or did i close
yet
i think i actually closed you to be fair
see even me being a good salesman
had to sell her on marrying me that was
a hard sale it was the best thing i ever
did oh you're very sweet
right so lastly lastly block viewings
yeah now when you've got two or three
tenants that you've all kind of filtered
and there and two or three of them are
like yeah man i want to take it and then
you show them round together yeah
oh my goodness you have got a 100 chance
of rain in that room and then the other
two are going to be disappointing and
you know what
good news
we do have another room in the same
house let me show you right okay so how
soon would you like to move in
great well what's going to happen now
here's the contract
how would you how would you like to pay
your your um
deposit yeah
boom shaka
deal
yeah block fumes are really really good
and it saves you time as the person
going you don't want to be going back
and forth wasting petrol wasting your
time so it's better to just have a block
view in turn up everyone's there at the
same time it almost as well i feel just
creates a sense of urgency because if
you feel like
oh i'm going to lose out because this
other person is there then people are
just you know more likely to act and
it's just i don't know it's just better
and also as well once you've got one or
two tenants then it's so easy to fill
the rest of the house because you can
just get referrals from the tenants yeah
exactly yeah yeah yeah like hey i'll
give you
a 50 pound
um 50 pound
cash prize
if you can put put a friend in and then
they'll be like who do i know that would
like a room and they'll fill the house
for you yeah so easy um we don't
normally talk too much about property on
the podcast we normally talk about money
marriage life but i guess
our life is property so it's hard to
keep property out of it i hope you
enjoyed this video i hope you enjoyed
this information you heard it from the
absolute amanda is the most underrated
property investor on the planet because
she doesn't make a big splash about what
she's doing but she's actually the
brains behind the operation the brains
beyond the operation
so let us know what you want to hear us
talk about next week comment below if
you've got specific questions
comment below this is your opportunity
now and next week we'll answer them
absolutely uh please do uh hit the like
button yeah and subscribe subscribe to
the channel and we'll see you guys next
time thanks for watching guys bye
[Music]